[Music]
you said that the meaning of life is to
win if you look five years into the
future what does winning look like so
[Music]
ah there's a lot of I can go into like
technical depth to what I mean by that
to win um it may not mean I was
criticized for that in the comments like
doesn't this guy want to like save the
penguins in Antarctica or like okay you
know listen to what I'm saying I'm not
talking about like I have a yacht or
something I am an agent I am put into
this world and I don't really know what
my purpose is but if you're a
reinforcement if you're if you're an
intelligent agent and you're put into a
world what is the ideal thing to do well
the ideal thing mathematically you go
back to like Schmitt Hoover theories
about this is to build a compressive
model of the world to build a maximally
compressive to explore the world such
that your exploration function maximizes
the derivative of compression of the
past
Schmidt Hooper has a paper about this
and like I took that kind of as like a
personal goal function um so what I mean
to win I mean like maybe maybe this is
religious but like I think that in the
future I might be given a real purpose
or I may decide this purpose myself and
then at that point now I know what the
game is and I know how to win I think
right now I'm still just trying to
figure out what the game is but once I
know so you have you have imperfect
information you have a lot of
uncertainty about the reward function
and you're discovering it exactly what
the purpose is that's that's the better
way to put it so yeah the purpose is to
maximize it while you have it a lot of
uncertainty around it and you're both
reducing the uncertainty and maximizing
at the same time yeah and so that's at
the technical level what is the if you
believe in the universal prior yeah what
is the universal law of award function
that's the better way to put it so that
when it's interesting I think I speak
for everyone in saying that I wonder
what that reward function is for you and
I look forward to seeing that in five
years in ten years I think a lot of
people who do myself right and cheering
you on man so I'm I'm a happy you exist
and I wish you the best of luck
you